amid Italy's stunning tuscan landscape
local residents are making a beeline for
one particular restaurant in the town of
Volterra
but it's no typical dining experience
they are lining up for they'll be eating
inside the walls of a high-security
prison Seth Doane secured a reservation
and found out more in a 13th century
fortress on the hill top of a Tuscan
town preparations were underway for a
rather unlikely dinner armed guards kept
watch above busy as the aperitivo was
laid out in the courtyard
and as Rosario Campania served for CEQA
he's also serving a 26 year sentence for
murder how is it to have all of these
folks here tonight
lee baedal freedom cleric a libero
do you see a prison here he asked
you see prison around us yep the 410
submitted Chia its 138 dinner guests
hors d'oeuvres and sparkling wine is a
prison in Volterra Italy it's home to
some of the country's most hardened
criminals and on eight nights a year its
post to a dinner where the prisoners do
all the work it's designed to raise
money for charity build skills and give
inmates the chance to interact with
those on the outside it's a whiff of
freedom said Vito's creepily oh pro
forma Delta serving life for murder and
that means happiness she added in the
kitchen these criminals who admit
they've made bad choices in the past are
more focused on the future who at least
the next few hours the pasta was thrown
into the pot at about twenty minutes to
ten this is Italy after all and then it
was mixed with a delicate parsley sauce
lifer Francesco inna Chanti is in for
aggravated murder salvie this is where
we are so this is where we must grow he
said it's like a plant it grows where
it's planted the real Grazia gem piccolo
is the warden she says the program
provides experiences both professional
and social it sounds good does it work a
pseudo mantis eat them they can
absolutely yes she said we've been doing
these dinners for over 11 years and
about 30 young men now work in
restaurants one owns a restaurant we've
raised over $140,000 for charity and had
over 14 thousand guests the prison
brings in guest chefs to teach the
inmates dinner was served in a former
church on the prison grounds Comanche Bo
the food got good reviews but the real
draw was the novelty how is it to be
having dinner inside a prison it's very
strange
because we don't know if we come and if
we come back joking aside by the end of
dinner curiosity had given way to a
connection prisoners sang a song they
wrote about togetherness and for a
moment inside this prison the walls
seemed to disappear CBS this morning
Saturday I'm Seth Dome in Volterra Italy
[Applause]
I love one of the the inmates that he
said this is where we are so this is
where we grow it is about rehabilitation
it looks like a really special night
what a great story